this is a steam guys standby on a city
street a group of pedophile hunters are
about to confront a suspected online sex
offender but against the wall good luck
right the reason why I'm here it's
because you've been talking to children
online and you've been using a fee to
count these things have been far fewer
in number since the lockdown but
activist groups say they've been using
that time to gather vast amounts of
evidence against suspected offenders
throughout this particular chat as
always the decoy is saying I'm 14 and 14
is that ok Josh Dobbs has helped track
down suspected online sex offenders for
more than five years
once the lockdown is fully lifted she
expects Peter far hunting groups to be
fully active again it expects a lot of
teams to be picking up where they've
left off but a lot of the cases have
been handed over to the police and a lot
of them have been worked by the police
as always there is a backlog when we are
handing it over so there are some cases
that haven't been worked on someone
expects that the teams would go out and
get those this decoy who poses as a 14
year old girl in online chat rooms says
the lockdown has led to a massive
increase in the number of men trying to
make contact with her before lockdown
use gained maybe 40 messages a day and
two days ago I had to hope over 208
messages let's just on one out
and are these people that know or
believe you're a 14 year old girl yeah
there's only a handful that will lock
the account limits or continue to talk
you've attempted to meet a child
following what's called sexual grooming
police chiefs have been trying to
encourage activist groups not to mount
these things and instead hand over their
evidence they're concerned about the
potential for these face-to-face
confrontations to go wrong we have seen
a number of suicides of people who've
been stung by these groups over the last
year but we're also
really concerned about when when
activist groups carry out their stings
they've got no mechanism by which they
can safeguard the children involved
Peter for hunting groups have told us
they often get frustrated at the lack of
action after passing evidence on to the
police
hey guys face-to-face confrontations
they say always ensure an immediate
police response mark white Sky News